welcome everybody i want to start today
with a foreign policy situation that is
quickly building and i want to highlight
uh some comments that were made which i
think are sort of the epitome of the
false simplification of the situation in
russia and ukraine now the context here
is we have a genuinely concerning
escalation in terms of russian
aggression or threatened aggression
implied aggression towards ukraine i
think we still don't really know
vladimir putin's true intentions on the
one side
once we consider 130 000 russian troops
massing at the ukrainian border with
significant military equipment and an
arsenal of various weapons we say well
putin's clearly planning to invade and
try to take ukraine
the other side would be putin has no
intention whatsoever of invading and
this is all
uh either
sort of a let's see what happens sort of
thing or even further some say this is
the logical reaction from russia
to the hostilities from ukraine and nato
allies saying maybe maybe maybe
ukraine will at some point become part
of nato which would be very much not to
vladimir putin's advantage now
i want to highlight some comments made
by former
i know it's weird to say former
democratic congresswoman tulsi gabbard
and a lot of you will say
she's almost exclusively appearing on
fox and giving pretty reactionary takes
what she she was a democrat when she was
um in the house of representatives i'm
just telling it to you like it is and
what tulsi gabbard says to tucker
carlson is really the epitome
of the false simplification that a
certain
wing and again i i don't even want to
call it a wing of the left because it's
what what views of hers are now really
left but it doesn't matter
this is a view on russia ukraine that is
really the epitome
of the
russia's the victim not the aggressor
and the u.s is primarily the bad actor
perspective and tulsi also takes it as
an opportunity not only generally to
criticize the united states but also to
criticize joe biden and here's her view
on how we de-escalate
the the russia ukraine situation take a
listen to this
oh first of all biden president biden
could
end this crisis and prevent a war
with russia by doing something very
simple guaranteeing that ukraine will
not become a member of nato because if
ukraine became a member of nato that
would put u.s and nato troops directly
on the doorstep of russia which
as putin has laid out would undermine
their national security interests
the reality is that it is highly highly
unlikely that ukraine will ever become a
member of nato anyway so the question is
why doesn't president biden and nato
leaders actually just say that yeah and
guarantee it
tucker loves it this is a this take is
perfect for fox news as you can see now
there's there's two major problems with
this and the reason i'm i'm using
tulsi's comments as an on-ramp to this
is because there's lots of people who
are saying
um
we we're goading the west is goading
ukraine i'm sorry the west is goading
russia
by maybe you know flirting with the
possibility that ukraine could become
part of nato and many of them say
a promise was made that that would never
be the case so joe it's joe biden so
there's two issues here first of all is
the the major issue of why can't we just
say
the best way to prevent an escalation is
for the aggressor to stop their
aggression okay i don't want war with
russia i don't want to attack russia i'm
not an imperialist i'm not a warmonger
i'm not any of those things but
we have to be able to say
that's the aggressor and the aggressive
action here is not that
ukraine joining nato hasn't been ruled
out well let's look at the simplest and
most direct form of aggression which is
what putin is doing with troops at the
border we just have to be able to say
what things are that's number one so
it's crazy to think you know tulsi was a
democratic candidate
and that she actually had the support of
a few percent of the democratic primary
electorate and they fell for it and they
supported her and these are these are
her takes but let's dig in a little more
into this nato piece
there's lots of people
like tulsi and others who sometimes kind
of pretend to be on the left but they're
really apologists for authoritarians and
one of the things they love to repeat
about russia ukraine is that there was a
promise made that nato would stop
expansion
and they would rule that ukraine will
there was a promise ukraine will never
be part of nato and ne and the real
source of aggression is starting to toy
with ukraine being part of nato this is
all based on a lie
there is no such promise and because
this is so prevalent in these
discussions where russia ends up being
defended
at the core of this is a lie
such a promise the promise that ukraine
would never join nato
was initially proposed verbally by the
german and u.s foreign ministries but it
was later rescinded by the heads of
government but bush and coal at the time
and it was never put on the table again
so there is no such promise that has
been codified and why does something so
obscure matter it matters because it
underlines the perspective of many of
these people on the situation
at the time
hans dietrich gentile of germany said
it's certain nato will never have troops
on east german soil
and some other promises that were made
there
but the statement was walked back it was
walked back and no such promises were
ever codified in any way it keeps
getting repeated nato broke its promise
nato is breaking its promise nato would
break its promise the u.s is breaking
its promise there is no such promise and
so the focus should be on the aggressors
and the aggressors here are putin and
russia
bigger picture
ukraine is a sovereign nation russia
doesn't get to say
we can legitimately be aggressive
because ukraine wants to join nato if
that's the case and so there are some
bad faith actors tulsi gabbard is one of
them who have sort of
uh manipulated and molded the situation
with lies by omission
uh and the like to create this
completely false narrative and
unfortunately there are some people on
the left that are falling forward so
we're going to continue trying to
make clear what really should be very
very clear
you can support the david pakman show by
supporting our sponsors and one of those
sponsors is sheath underwear
traditional underwear involves sticking
sweating the dreaded chafing sheath
underwear are boxer briefs
specifically designed to keep everything
separate cool dry and comfortable they
have a bunch of great designs options to
choose from more minimal styles their
signature geometric pattern waistband is
cool there's really something for
everybody but the most important thing
is you stay cool during the day and at
night
upping your comfort to the next level
read the reviews online sheath underwear
has been a game changer for many men
give it a try they have super fast
shipping you'll get your order in just a
few days and don't forget that you'll
get twenty percent off when you go to
sheath underwear dot com slash pacman
and use the code pacman the link is down
below